so playing a lot of lawbreakers recently
and I wanted to give you guys kind of my
first a pen my first impression or an
opinion on what to think of the game
sofa regarding some of the characters
most of them feel enjoyable and balanced
except - - - I'm really talking about
though our Wraith and Titan in my
opinion in the community's opinion ray
seems to be powerful at the moment a
little bit too powerful comes in coming
equipped in the machine pistol dealing
incredible damage when bursted to an
insane mobility on par with maybe even
better than assassin you might not be he
might need to rework but maybe everyone
hasn't gotten time to know the character
or find his weaknesses but for who knows
right now at this moment he seems a bit
over a bit powerful for this game at
this current time Titan though on the
other hand is the complete opposite
Titan is just kind of standard heavy
class low mobility heavy damage in a
game room ability key he's already a
disadvantage not being able to sprint or
have a good mobility button that
requires him to gain fast speed on top
of that he seems very situational and
would probably excel more at holding an
objective than rushing into a firefight
overall though the characters are all
different in their own way and support
any play style you do prefer ranging
from sitting back like gunslinger and
battle medic so running and gunning like
rape and enforcer the maps in the game
feel great and look stunning and
beautiful multiple access points into
rooms enough space to have air comp have
air combat but not overdoing it to feel
cramped to open a lot of choke points
there are stash jobs there are RNG
things but they're all completely
cosmetic and it doesn't really seem to
bother me as much this is a really
really short video and it's just more
about my first impressions I've been
playing a game I've been playing the
game a little bit not too much I'll
probably start making a better detailed
review on this game once it's either out
of beta or getting very near toward that
and then for the other people that are
always here for for honor
like I said boys I got you guys covered
so don't you worry about that this is
just something else I always wanted to
do but anyway I'll see you guys later
though and peace out